♪♪
Hey!
Oh!
-Ted Lasso welcome-wagon has
arrived!
(Cheers)
Ted Lasso.
Ted Lasso is-
-An injection of goodness.
Woo-hoo! Ugh!
Oh!
-Ah!
I'm fine.
The level of thanks that comes
across social media...
Hannah:
Imagine getting tweets
from people saying,
Hannah:
"We're kinder to each other in
our family because you've
Hannah:
reminded us that that's what we
should all be."
It's a choice, isn't it, to be
positive and grateful and I now
find myself saying,
Brett:
"I appreciate you," to most
people after an interaction.
This is why it's hard to love
you.
Oh!
He loves you!
The positivity that people have
felt about the show and talking
about the kind
of "Lasso Way," being very funny
but also very human. It's
undeniable.
Keep an eye on these guys
because around the seventy-four
minute mark,
there's gonna be a room full of
grown men crying.
I'll be one of them.
Every man and woman is living a
comedy, a drama and a tragedy,
and the message is reflecting
that notion.
Speaking with people and the
fans and the reactions changed
my life.
Cristo:
I was walking and randomly a
person just starts
going, "Football is life!
Football is life!"
Football is life.
Someone who messaged me on
Twitter said their eleven year
old son missed a shot that
would've tied the game and she's
like, "Right, I know you're
upset
but what do we need to do?" And
he goes, "Be a goldfish like
Sam."
You remember what animal has the
shortest memory?
A goldfish.
What do you think we should all
do once we get done being sad?
I think we should all be a
goldfish.
I brought you a little
something.
-Oh?
Yeah, cookies.
Or, as y'all call them here,
biscuits.
I've been getting a lot of
biscuit recipes. People going,
"Oh, look at these that we
made," or little videos of them
going, "Oh my God, they
taste as good as yours!" And who
knew that that whole Biscuits
With The Boss thing
would go so nuts?
Ted:
I forgive you.
Why?
Divorce is hard. It makes folks
do crazy things.
♪♪
Jason:
Some of the more profound
responses that have reached me personally have been from people
going through things that
characters are going through on
the show or just something
that's really taken hope out of
their hearts. And how the show
moved them in a way
Jason:
that refilled their Love Cup, so
to speak.
Oh, it feels good to laugh.
And season two is even better.
♪♪
Season two stays as adorable as
the first.
How long was I out?
Doesn't matter, you're back now.
Let's do this.
Ohhh!
(Spits)
Woo-hoo!
You listen to me, Coach Lasso.
We have work to do.
Next season.